hi thank you for coming and yeah I
really yeah we we talked about our
ideals of successful methods to build a
smart noise filter and I will do more
like the background and the motivation
part and Iceland who implemented it will
speak about the technology I will try to
keep it short so to speak about myself
I'm up to make open technologies free
and accessible so I in fact sample to
Iraq just to work with pupils Arvin to
Presley for human right of internet
access and I came up to build smart
noise figure so what was actually the
motivation behind it's a kind of very
personal in that moment so I've some
hearing problem myself and I went to
doctor and it called me saying me I have
a blast Rama like from a short or
something like that
I was hot you know and then I remembered
I know short I know I made rim shots
when I was playing cram said so that's
actually killing my good hearing and so
it looks like this when you look my
hearing craft it is like the higher the
higher parents I don't usually and this
is for some reason it's a similar
problem like many people have I will
explain this later so I thought I tried
out some hearing aids and I found all
this mmm not really
I mean it's uncool when design is uncool
sound is uncool not self fitting is also
really uncool if you like up to open
technology it's it sounds strange then
somebody tells you what you should hear
it's no good
so I made up the idea - yeah - to do
something about it
and I found also out that many many many
people have these problems it's about I
mean think about it 360 millions of
people all around the world and many of
them don't even have access to health
health care and most I was like quarter
for us older than 65 we'll have a
problem with hearing aid quite similar
like my one and mostly people don't use
hearing aids because of the reasons I
have two and so I said it's not only
affecting me it's affecting a lot of
people so I should do something about it
and I started scientific research in
citizen science projects together with
other people think about open source
technology for hearing support and it's
still running it's at Fraunhofer I DMT
here you can really not on my laptop yes
so we gotta have also hackathon soon I
mean you can speak to me afterwards
but anyway what's important about this
point is but I do is actually open
source hearing aid algorithms testing in
real-life situations and people are self
fitting it so I speak to a lot of people
what would you like to hear but it's a
good sound for you and not only for
people who have hearing problem for all
kind of people that's actually and then
I what I found out actually this many
people feel disturbed by noise all kind
of noise we are a surround it with
traffic noise for example I mean streets
trains airplanes all kind of power
stations machines air conditioners all
kind of Cooling's
and even little it's not so loud noises
can mix can cause stress like this
electric calendar or beamers other video
project just ascension we must video
projectors it's usual that I feel
disturbed by because often the video
projector is between
and that one who's speaking so it's hard
to understand so or even subwoofers are
it's also little like sounds like the
keyboard pressing which can disturb I
think everybody knows is from from his
situation making crazy and so actually
it's like whisper I would guess such a
pressing of keyboards and this is not
for the Chairman statutory accident
insurance below you see but decibel like
this pressing of keyboard it's not noise
you wouldn't get any protect for your
for your work and if you go up to 80
decibels its traffic noise and should
actually wear ear protection so it makes
sense for lots lots of people do
something about it
and there's other kind of things like
the cocktail party effect I think you
know about is that when a lot of people
are speaking when you start have a
little bit of problems of in your triad
it's hard to listen to once noise so the
idea is what could we do just to turn it
off so I thought about make a
selectively personalized noise filter
and that's the point where I met Iceland
and the idea behind this to make it
accessible means open source to use open
source databases to make it transparent
makes it deep learning algorithm
transparent means that you have used a
controlled machine learning and that you
I mean also share the knowledge and
involve people in the development and
this is actually is Eisley in part now
because she took sole thing to tribute a
notebook involving deep learning and
signal processing alright hi I'm Alan
Rose another really important point that
we wanted the software to be able to do
was to be able to run on for example
smartphones or raspberry pies another
element of accessibility and that meant
so whatever algorithms or architectures
that we implemented we pulled from
research with a you know with similar
goals of implementing good sound filters
and deep neural architectures so that
they could be implemented on a
smartphone I have a master's degree in
clinical linguistics so of course I am
the developer of this software makes
sense I know that everyone must be
familiar with clinical linguistics but
I'll humor you and explain it anyways
I've basically studied how one can study
language processing and development in
the brain by using language in all
different forms so measuring how people
measuring brain waves when people are
reading or how people process
information acoustically but we're here
to talk today about a smart noise filter
we heard about Peggy's motivation to
build this and I will walk you through a
bit of the architecture and what that
looks like so let's say you are
programming at home home office and you
open the window and you have you know a
nice breeze
somebody's playing guitar outside but
unfortunately you also live on a street
so there's cars how nice is that
wouldn't it be so nice to be able to
have oh oh good ok have the breeze in
there with with just the guitar and not
the traffic this is the goal of the
software someday we would really love it
to be able to doing this real-time it's
not quite to that point yet but it's on
its way it is able to do this pulling
from two fields so digital signal
processing and deep learning Bay quick
raise of hands how many people are
familiar with spectrograms
oh great ok so quite a few not everybody
all righty so whenever we have a you
know this our sound signal here this is
a nickel space when we digitalize it you
know it's we all have seen this it's a
wave it looks like this but let's say
you want to understand a bit more of
what's in that complex signal you apply
the Fourier transform
there will be no quiz so just know that
the Fourier transform is an equation
that when you apply it to for example a
digitized wave or a sound wave it
informs you or it shows with the
frequencies that are in the signal and
how much energy they have so you're
looking at right now a spectrogram of
some traffic and music this picture is
then sent on to a convolutional neural
network and CNN's are a great form of
neural network that works very well in
you know in data efficiency so if you
need it running on a smartphone the
convolutional neural network is a great
way to go
this convolutional neural network it's
been trained to identify annoying
background noises so air conditioning
traffic luckily it identified traffic
here and it told the Wiener filter now
the Wiener filter there are many filters
out there for example a spectral filter
a spectral filter just takes this like
basically spectrum this the spectrogram
here and it just subtracted from the
first signal and what results is a lot
of the times very annoying musical noise
it's it's really ugly despite the name
and what the Wiener filter does is in a
low computational manner it it is able
to you know reduce this specific kind of
traffic noise from the signal while also
maintaining as you know the least amount
of distortion as possible so here we
have a nice filtered signal of just the
just a guitar if there's anybody out
there
who
like this guy don't worry I before I do
have a background in clinical
linguistics I got interested in
acoustics and all that could be
extrapolated from that signal and learn
to build helpful tools specifically
knowing that researchers are training
neural networks on speech data to
potentially in a very early point in
time to identify if diseases are
developing you know not only does that
help in identifying a disease earlier in
the development but it was also more
accessible so people across the planet
could be able to use that technology
with their smartphone for example so
that's what got me started but it was
one hell of a ride
hardener it was one ride to get from
there to here to developing this and so
I had two goals well in this process one
goal was to get a good sound filter
running but another one at using deep
learning but another one was to make the
pathway a bit easier particularly in the
Python community to do this for people
to do this on their own if they would
like to what I found to be missing in
this especially Python community there's
some elements there which is great but
there's much room for growth there there
are a number of resources to you know
get into filtering or deep learning and
everything but what I found difficult
especially with sound data was to
actually interact with it so I wanted to
make this project a bit of a sound
playground now what do you need for a
playground or what what what I think
about what I think of a playground
stress-free you don't have to sit there
and think about maintenance or whatever
you know you get to have you know the
jungle gym to climb around and the
trampolines or what have you so it it it
matches an interest to pay you know for
of people of all abilities and
backgrounds
I utilized both Jupiter lab and
notebooks AI how many of you use those
tools
Jupiter lab and notebook so da cool all
right well for those of you who are not
familiar I'm glad that I could introduce
you to this basically what you can do
here is you know notebooks that III they
offer a place where you can upload
actually some information like data I
was able to upload some sample data for
people to play around with and Jupiter
lab just allows you to work with the
code see visualizations etc alright so
now what kind of playground activities
are there so let's say you're somebody
like me who was coming from a definite
not digital signal processing background
you want to understand a lot better you
know what actually is going on one
example that I have here is this is a
this is a way to you know create a
signal it's a very simple signal but I
would see it you don't have to
understand all the code or anything like
that but for me it was really difficult
to penetrate that I didn't know what I
could do with that I didn't know what
all of that stuff meant so in one of my
little playground areas this again you
don't need to understand everything here
but the point is in the indie functions
come is just simply a context context is
added in these functions so that you
know one can piece together okay the
unit circle what is this I didn't think
about the unit circle since high school
but it is an integral element to
understanding how to work with sound
whether that be creation manipulation
and auto analysis the Fourier transform
relies on the unit circle and again
that's true Fourier transform it takes
what's in this time domain
into the frequency domain this time
domain picture on the left this like
block of wave you can't really see that
much in the in the picture on the right
you can see there's three different
frequency signals in there more
information there all right so let's say
you are more interested in filtering and
you just want to see can we use this
software to work with your own problem
in a low computational accessible way
here in another notebook what you can
see here I can't play any of them for
you but you can use data that has been
uploaded here and ready for you or you
can also add your own files if you would
like you can play them within the
notebook and here are some can you see
here with noise not filter signal the
the simplest implementation is just what
you would like to save it under and then
this the file that you would like to
save it as or some that you want to
remove the noise of alright so you play
it the filter is you know either not
strong enough
you know let's make it a lot stronger
you can add another parameter or is it
here scale you know I want to increase
the scale alright so lets you you
increase the scale but you know what
even though it's a great wiener filter
you still hear some of this annoying
musical noise and distortion there is a
post filter as well and this post filter
it it simply aims to reduce that
annoying you know annoying musical noise
if you like alrighty
no networks there I have notice that
there's a lot of opportunities to work
with you know computer vision you know
with image recognition and everything
but not that much working with sound so
here especially understanding what sound
data is or what it looks like two of the
most common
feature types if you don't know this
it's okay these are more keywords that
you can maybe check out later our mell
frequency cap stroke coefficients or MSC
CS as well as log mel filter bank
energies i for me it took a long time to
understand kind of what what these even
just looked like how how do they differ
and here you can visualize okay so with
this word it's somebody saying zero what
does this look like in features of you
know but when the MF cc's are extracted
great compared with the same word when
these F Bank features are extracted here
you can actually see how sounds are
being made zero
oops no that's not what I wanted so
that's just an example of how to you
know get some more familiar with what
you're actually working here if you
continue working with sound you'll come
across windowing in a different context
but this is a windowing of feature
extraction what does it look like what
does it do to your data when you
increase or decrease the size of your
window or you know the shift so here's
an example you have a window size of 20
milliseconds oh gosh sorry wrong way and
vs. down here window size of 100
milliseconds you can see the but the one
below is quite a bit foggier and maybe
not us not not so helpful training your
own classifier what I like about this is
this is based off of a pretty simple
convolutional neural network you can
train this data on either sound data for
example traffic like we did traffic air
conditioning or also on speech so here I
was actually able to upload a small
segment of a small section of these
Google speech sound a speech commands
data set here
and just being able to get a bit of a
feeling for how training on neural
network on these two different data
types speech versus sound or sorry room
background noise how that influences
training of the model now let's say you
want to you know expand your skills in
building your own architectures trying
out different filtering techniques or
just manipulating a little bit what code
you see is up there you have the source
code right there in the notebook here's
an example the model here is defined or
is like the architecture is put together
here all one would really have to do is
go into this function here and try out
another kind of functionality or another
kind of architecture that you would like
to explore maybe you would even want to
try a long short-term memory network you
can you have the ability to go into that
code yourself and address that easier
said than done alright so another
question that I have for you is given
your own unique experience as well as
educational background what would you
like to do with you know sound yourself
ours looked like this what might yours
look like and now I will give the stage
back to Peggy to talk about our future
visions some amplification hey I'm back
again so it's a very complex and
beautiful implementation and but it's
still hard to make it real time in real
life so it's sound so cool by deep
learning to just switch off sound you
don't light but actually at the moment
we are happy if we can do it on sound
files and you know take a sound file
let's filter running through it and have
a clean more or less clean sound file
and so for future ideas there's lots
lots to do
so on one side make the delay perfect
that sounds real time and the other side
it's still working on only on laptop put
it on mobile device for example loose
use Raspberry Pi we have some hardware
set up like for sale support check we
could take for it would be amazing and
the other point is open data it's big
big issue because in the meanwhile even
in research we have problems to have
enough especially sound data to train
our systems services should think about
it how could we support and get bra open
data and do we want to develop something
on output data and yeah of course it
would be perfect you have open tell that
you used together with a cloud with with
an app you can feed you can exchange
data you can even exchange presets you
know like you say I'm standing here in
front of cosmos and I'm in the cloud and
I have my headphones on and III see
Peter as he has good very good database
and good fit presets let's take his
preset of perfect you know like with
cable s for example Bluetooth headphones
or ear plugs it should work okay so I am
still ticking on it to develop it
further
speak to me join packed up space which
is actually the label I'm running and I
invite you to to join and yeah of course
we have the repository if anyone wants
to contribute we are really really very
happy if you want to go on with Iceland
sound playground do it support system
some
debugging a bit uh-huh necessary and yes
since I had and there is AC next
meetings we have next next Saturday we
have the open source diversity workshop
where we gonna play around with the
tribute and out book and for some for
the non Hoffa project we can have a
hackathon I invite you to to join its
8th and 9th of November in Berlin and we
gonna speak also about the noise filter
and as a open source implementations and
possible hardware setups to realize that
it's also coming some companies like
Pickering 8 is a developer like skylight
no ok and now and yeah ok so if you feel
like joining speak to us and yes that's
actually the end of our talk thank you
for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You pagan hasn't given questions
yes I know
thanks for your interesting talk I was
just wondering so you are using the CNN
to identify the noise within a signal
have you looked at more like classical
established noise filtering methods like
just taking a sample of the noise from a
signal and extracting it from the signal
I know this for example exists in like
this bose noise-canceling headphones for
example yeah one thing that this
software would also like to do one
example is you're talking with somebody
and you hear some nice music in the
background but you also hear maybe some
air conditioning that you would really
like not like to have if you were to
just take the background noise you would
lose maybe also the music that you would
really like to have as well so that's
that is kind of the direction that we
would like to go in is maybe a source
separation so being able to separate
these sounds which is difficult to do
when we just have one microphone and
right now we just have one microphone
imagine your head just with one ear it's
a lot more difficult we use the two
years a lot to help us focus our
attention but that with in with our with
the mind in you know which direction we
want to go into and that is more to
choose which sounds we want to be able
to experience just taking you know a
block of background noise it doesn't
really allow us to get to that goal hey
thank you very much for the talk and for
sharing your vision maybe two questions
first one if you could tell us tell me a
little bit more about potential see for
learning these filters that you'd like
to apply and second any architectures
you see like available right now
something you prefer for maybe
blowing on micro processors anything so
my questions thanks okay well the
learning for the filter what exactly I
don't quite understand what you mean
there what do you mean I was thinking if
these these Wiener filters are of low
computational complexity maybe these are
like I don't know it's like one filter
that you sort of hard is sort of hard
coded and you just apply it and maybe
you could adapt this or learn this from
sounds and from noise or so I don't know
because because it's new to me
I was wondering yeah I mean it would be
cool this is all definitely an
explorative field I think this was the
first version to see that it could
actually work how can we use deep
learning it like i have i have a
background and applying deep learning to
sound so that's why we went first
applying it to actually you know scene
recognition but i'm also interested in
how you know we can apply machine
learning techniques and you know the the
actual setting up of the filter and that
is yeah somewhere down down the road i i
don't know yet and regarding the
architectures it's one one issue there
is what your goal is that this is the
first time that I've ever tried to get
something running on for example a
smartphone or a like a small device and
you know I I always thought about
getting something up on the cloud and
you know if you are trying to get
something running on the cloud you have
a lot more freedom as to what you know
what kind of architectures you want to
use so that's something that you need to
consider is what what do you want your
end purpose to be and that can result in
quite a variety in your architectural
choice so forth what's the hard way
we're asking about the hardware someone
is actually something next is running on
very fast smartphones like anza pixel
and an iPhone but its own aside and
smartphones at the moment doing so and
it seems like it is necessary that you'd
need a code which is quite made for the
for the processor to make it perfect so
we have
molten sauce processes which are but
they're not up to date at the moment
this would be NASA issued to think about
make takes this open source present I
say a processor and make it new there
are some research projects Peaks
research projects which are also making
making up new new processor generation
for hearing support but there are all
closed source and yeah and this also
sees I mean it's different different
things about the thing about for example
is a wireless issue is also big issue
because you have a big delay firstly USB
usually but you have the next generation
of my fuse B now from from iPhone which
is actually going in real time and is
also not the idea to to see Vance's next
is a USB 3 known as really Sarah when it
will be three isn't it the new version
it will be open source it will be also a
big possibility to to make it happen
without wire because briars are always
disturbing this is a this is very I mean
in impractical this yeah I'll be running
out okay so we speak afterwards thank
you very much all right thanks